[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue donc dans son caddie
avec didier deyris bonjour bonjour et
bonjour aux éditeurs des réponses élus
de la chambre de commerce et d'industrie
de la martinique référent pour les
questions internationales et notre
interview ce matin porte sur l'objectif
de booster l'export des entreprises dans
la caraïbe et plus particulièrement dans
la caraïbe de l'est alors de le cadre
général on va contextualiser didier
deyris aujourd'hui encore en 2018 la
martinique et change peu avec son
environnement régional immédiat 1 y
compris donc les pays les plus proches
de la caraïbe de l'est et je crois que
les exportations vers la caraïbe
représente à peu près 3 % de nos
exportations globales
donc ça veut dire que peu des changes
vers cette partie
pourtant très proche de nous du monde ça
veut dire qu'il y a encore des parts de
marché à conquérir il ya des
perspectives effectivement qui peuvent
être encourageante
de ce point de vue bien tout à fait donc
si vous voulez le la chambre de commerce
donc afin dans le cadre du plan de
mandature de 2,7
on a mis en place un certain nombre
d'objectifs et l'un de ses objectifs
justement c'est s'ouvrir sur la caraïbe
c'est pour ça que le disons que ce que
ce que je préside fait le maximum pour
vous voir faire en sorte que les
entreprises martiniquaises haye sur la
caraïbe très bien et pour cela il y à un
nouvel outil qui a été présenté hier
il s'agit du tic a alors ça s'écrit t2
au ca ca vient donc d'une expression en
tout cas d'une formule anglaise un trade
and death man for eastern caribbean sa
part donné ma prononciation
on peut traduire globalement
perfectionnement renforcement commercial
pour la caraïbe de l'est alors c'est un
programme unique qui est portée
effectivement par la cci de martinique
et qui s'adresse plus particulièrement
didier deyris aux primo exportateurs
vers cette zone de l'océan le lot c'est
au donc
la caraïbe de laisse donc à ceux qui
cherchent à exporter pour la première
fois qu'ils connaissent pas encore bien
ce marché c'est exactement ça c'est à
dire c'est renforcement des relations
commerciales entre la caraïbe orientale
et la martinique et il s'agit donc de
dinde un projet extrêmement extrêmement
importants comme vous dites qu'ils
s'adressent aux primo accédants haut
niveau au niveau des gens qui vont ils
vont sur la caraïbe
alors c'est un projet qui d'abord c'est
un projet interreg
c'est un projet interreg donc les
projets intérêts qui sont des projets
qui sont cofinancés le sanglot financé
par l'europe mais qui s'adresse à une
relation entre entre la martinique dont
il faut que ce soit un porteur
martiniquais qui s'y est enfin
martiniquais et guadeloupéens guyanais
qui porte le projet donc dans le cadre
de ce projet c'est effectivement la
chambre de commerce
et puis des partenaires caribéen alors
il faut savoir que la martinique est
rentré dans l'eau dont la hausse et au
donc l'organisation de l'état de la
caraïbe orientale et donc ce projet
atika c'est le premier projet
d'importance qui étiez menés au sein de
ce2 de la caraïbe par la martinique
alors peut-être que certains ont
tendance à se dire bon bakary petit
marché pas forcément toujours de gros
pouvoir d'achat ici ou là
alors bien évidemment il faut
complètement nuancer cette appréciation
et vous vous allez plus loin et vous dis
carrément il faut il ne faut pas
sous-estimer le marché caribéen qui
offre 2 qui pourrait offrir en tout cas
de belles perspectives à nos
entrepreneurs alors qu'est-ce qui qu'est
ce qui vous fait dire ça qu'est ce qui
vous permet même de pouvoir l'affirmer
bien je vais vous dire très simplement
nous avons donc déjà fait un certain
nombre de projets sur la carène
on a amené des entreprises dans sur des
forums sur des marchés etc etc ces
entreprises ont vu
le chiffre d'affaires considérablement
augmenté grâce à aux échanges avec la
caraïbe donc il faut il faut jamais
sous-estimer a marché il faut savoir que
par exemple à sainte-lucie il ya de très
grands hôtels qui qui ont souvent besoin
de produits et les produits martiniquais
qui sont souvent de très bonne qualité
sont très appréciés alors donc on vous
avait parlé de intérêt tout à l'heure
qu'il ya effectivement un accompagnement
technique mais aussi un soutien
financier à travers ce tic à voilà alors
donc donc en fait d'abord si vous voulez
que le tic à cette cci un certain nombre
de partenaires qui intervient danticat
ya d'abord le le la ctm puisque vous
avez monsieur pro marie-jeanne étaient
présents il y a le organise s'appelle le
céda il ya un organisme qui s'appelle le
cbo ce sont donc des partenaires qui
sont à sainte lucie en dominique est
également à l'université des west indies
le parme et c'est donc en fait il ya un
certain nombre de partenaires qui
travaillent avec nous et l'idée si vous
voulez c'est de permettre pour à travers
ce projet aux entreprises de sable de se
projeter dans l'appareil dans
d'excellentes conditions
donc il va ya voir si vous voulez deux
organisations qui vont être mis en place
une norme martinique et une à sainte
lucie et on va on va donc choisir un
certain nombre d'entreprises dont il est
prévu de choisir une trentaine
d'entreprises pour pouvoir les aider les
booster à l'international mais il y a
également au sein de ce projet un
principe de mutualisation et de
partenariats qui est extrêmement
important et qui va permettre à des
entreprises martiniquaises même si elles
n'ont pas été
sélectionnez de rentrer dans le projet
tic à et d'adhérer à une espèce de
famille de l'entreprise si bien que si
par exemple une entreprise à sainte
lucie a besoin de lunettes parce qu'elle
n'est pas suffisamment fort pour vous
voir les sur un marché elle pourra
prendre une entreprises martiniquaises
et ensemble gagner un marché
donc c'est un partenariat qu'on pourrait
appeler win-win c'est-à-dire gagnant
gagnant didier deyris début de la
chambre de commerce et d'industrie
référent pour les questions
internationales je vous entend beaucoup
parler de sainte-lucie mais est-ce qu'il
ya d'autres marchés dans cette partie de
la caraïbe qui pourrait qu'ils
attendraient d'éventuels exportateurs
alors je vous ai de martinique je
voulais parler de sainte-lucie parce que
on est très présent là bas mais le lot
et ses os et 9 c 9
il donc ça concerne notamment 5,25
grenadine grenade
donc ça lui si dominique montserrat
5-6 nevis les virgin djilobodji british
virgin islands en anguille anguilla est
donc en fait il ya tous ces marchés qui
sont ils sont là maintenant
ce qui est important aussi c'est que les
gens qui sont dans ces marchés ils ont
accès aux cariforum et le cariforum
c'est un grand marché sur la karim qui
intègre également des dpi amérique et
d'amérique centrale donc en fait c'est
un très gros marché auquel on accorde
donc ce qu'on peut le haut ces eaux peut
servir de tête de pont à quelque sorte
c'est exactement ça s'est arrêté je
dirais même un vieux non seulement ça
permet d'embrasser donc ce marché là
mais ça me permet d'aller plus loin
parce que ils sont directement en
relation avec les etats-unis le canada
et c'est donc donc ça permet aux
entreprises martiniquaises d'accéder à
un marché qu'il est l'heure était à peu
fermé jusqu'à maintenant
alors ce programme tic a dit vous doit
permettre à ces entrepreneurs qui
voudrait donc conquérir le l'appela une
partie de ce marché caribéen et pour la
première fois
ça leur permet avant de se lancer de
bien identifier le marché
l'environnement législatif et des
partenaires potentiels
donc en fait vous aider à faire des
études de marché est très très pointue
très poussée c'est si on comprend bien
on pourrait dire ça on pourra dire ça
baptisé alésia désire donc en fait il
s'agit effectivement de permettre aux
entreprises d'aller d'aller sur les
marchés dans de bonnes conditions parce
que c'est sûr que aller sur des marchés
où on ne connaît pas la législation on
ne connaît pas là les modes de
fonctionnement juridique
sociaux etc c'est pas évident et donc on
va simplifier un petit peu le travail à
travers ces plateformes pour pour ces
entreprises
et puis on va vraiment amener les
entreprises à aller vers de la
mutualisation c'est à dire que le
principe c'est on est plus forts
ensemble tout seul et donc c'est mettre
en place des systèmes qui permettent de
mutualiser aussi bien avec des
entreprises martiniquaises entre elles
contrôler nos entreprises martiniquaises
et l'océan alors avant d'en venir à des
informations très pratique puisque bon
il faut quand même s'inscrire et puis on
va reparler de ce accompagnement de cet
accompagnement qui qui dure deux ans qui
assure une durée de deux ans mais dites
moi qu'est ce qui avec cet outil vous
permet de dire que là on sera plus
efficace que l'objectif peut vraiment
être atteints qu est ce qui fait la
différence par rapport à ce qu'il
pouvait exister auparavant parce que
c'est la première fois qu'on parle
d'aider les entreprises à exporter vers
la caraïbe
là avec ti-cats qu'est ce qui peut faire
vraiment la différence déjà si vous
voulez le fait de le fait de leur
permettre de gérer tout l'environnement
normatif réglementaires juridiques
sociales etc
c'est quand même quelque chose de très
important parce que parce que 38 quand
les entreprises arrivent dans un pays en
général sont un peu seul et il faut
trouver des relais et c'est souvent un
certain nombre de choses comme la
barrière de la langue d'ailleurs qui
font que que c'est pas facile mais il ya
déjà beaucoup d'entreprises qui ont
clients qui ont fait le pas et et qui
ont toujours assez bien marché donc donc
je pense que ce produit là va vraiment
boosté le l'aller vers le vers
l'exportation
et puis comme je dis c'est laisser là la
possibilité de trouver des partenariats
qui est très importante très bien aller
pour conclure donc je disais à la clé il
y à un accompagnement sur une durée de
deux ans ça met en pour cela il faut
s'inscrire
donc s'il ya une campagne d'inscription
qui commence dès aujourd'hui voilà on
donc la campagne d'inscription c'est
commence le 1er février donc ça démarre
aujourd'hui surtout sur tout le mois de
février donc on a vu toutes les
entreprises qui souhaitent s'inscrire à
ce programme à contacter la chambre de
commerce pour pouvoir s'inscrire ensuite
il y aura un jury qui va sélectionner un
certain nombre d'entreprises qui vont
être
qui vont pouvoir tellement pouvoir
bénéficier de ça et puis après le
prologue tout ça va commencer et vous
voyez ça a commencé par une
mutualisation fort on va faire une
réunion et on va expliquer aux gens
comment on doit mutualiser les choses
sur la caraïbe
merci didier des risques d'avoir répondu
à nos questions
[Musique]